we actually have in our et vault some
footage of your dad watching you as
jungle boy what did your dad think of
this he was all about it here yeah yeah
he actually grew up loving Dusty Rhodes
so it's it's cool to be with Cody now
and like how it's all turned out but you
use a big wrestling fan and he actually
was the one who pushed me to get trained
and start wrestling in the first place
oh wow I was just at the once upon a
time in Hollywood premiere Oh day and a
half ago yeah and while I was there I
saw you beautiful tribute on Instagram
talked to Tarantino about it yeah so
what inspired you to climb the Billboard
you know it can I kind of just had to do
it that's um I like climbing stuff and I
saw it there and um you know I just
wanted to you know it'll only be there
for so long and I kind of wanted to
commemorate it being there forever in a
way and you know it's kind of just my
natural thing to go climb on someone and
Quinten had mentioned he said you know
it's a beautiful of a touching tribute
and then mentioned to me that you worked
on the movie yeah you you can see me if
you pay close attention okay and what
scene it's in a movie theater okay yeah
so keep your eyes peeled oh that's
fabulous so what was it like paying on
that's crazy kind of suddenly I'm
shooting about can you make it Quinton
Tarantino these are all people that you
hear about all the time and it's they're
kind of just out there though in the
universe and so then to like to talk to
them and to be there with that it's like
like that's the guy right there that's
it and it's just a wild it's a wild
experience so you obviously saw the
movie what did you think was it hard to
watch it was a little bit but I was I
was very proud of it and
you know my dad was really proud of it
he was really excited about it and so it
was it was cool to see that and I'm glad
he got to do that it was really good for
him
but it was crazy movie I don't really
describe yeah you can't I'm like there's
Brad and Leo and then it's just a lot of
stuff yeah one more thing you know we
were just at comic-con and we sat down
with the cast of 90210 and Riverdale and
everyone's planning these tributes and
stuff I want to hear from you what do
you what do you make of all that and are
you touched you like it is it too much
would dad like it yeah I mean you know I
think the thing the thing that I'm most
proud of about my dad always say he was
a really good guy um and you know
obviously not everyone got the chance to
know him but I think he kind of the the
outreach and support I think it kind of
shows that and so you know I'm happy to
see it he was very he was loved by
everybody and I'm it's nice to see that
from everybody and you know it's a nice
thing is it hard to share that grief
with like the whole world yes and no I
mean I appreciate it
I knew him obviously in a way that that
no one else did so I can't relate fully
to people not everyone gets it but I
think everyone gets it in their own way
and that's nice to see I think everyone
feels it in their own way I thought it
was cool that Shannon is joining yes
yeah that'll be cool that's a cool
moment want to know from each of you how
you got involved in elite wrestling how
did the call come Lucas I had a kind of
Twitter no I was yeah so my call was a
DM and I thought it was somebody playing
a joke on me
because I'm a bit you know so I in
wrestling you you have your talent
persona your talent goggles you also
have your fan goggles yeah because I
firmly believe if you aren't a fan of
what we do then it's gonna show so I
still wear my fan goggles very proudly
so being a fan of Kenny Omega I get a
message from Kenny Omega when does that
ever happen right so I'm like yeah okay
sure thing
and I'm like tracking it down like
googling and it's like oh wait no this
this might be the real deal
so so we exchanged actual information
and have the contact and it was like oh
this is the real thing okay
stuck through Twitter what it 2019 you
know oh my gosh how about you you know
Brandi and I go way back and when they
had all in and Chicago was like big and
great I hadn't done anything in
wrestling for a long time because I've
been doing glow and kind of just took a
step back from wrestling and when I got
the call Brian went and seen my friend
and agent said you know they want to do
something so they cooked up an idea a
treat for the fans for awesome Kong
returned I hadn't been seen in three
years and no one saw coming
it was great mine was also through
Twitter I know I know I just got a
Twitter this I actually I - from Cody
but um I was in Chicago with my family
and my sister was getting ready to go to
Africa she's been in Africa for like six
months building preschools and things so
we were there kind of having our goodbye
weekend with her we were at breakfast
and my phone buzz and I looked at in his
message from Cody Rhodes and it had his
phone number he said shoot me a text
when you can you know I kind of figured
what was coming so I stepped outside the
restaurant
I knew snow and freezing cold enough
from California and I used to times out
there my short sleeve shirt shivering
and all that but um yeah I texted back
and forth with him a little bit and I
was pretty much it but yeah it was a
wild moment what do you think makes
elite wrestling different than other
wrestling programs that exist I think
the fact that all the wrestlers together
have input on the product it's just not
this one line of a constituency of one
and one person's idea here's the idea
trickle down and you perform it like
monkeys together as talent we have the
input and the ears are listening for us
to present our art to the world you are
changing the game I mean what a
trailblazer the first ever transgender
woman to sign a contract with a
professional wrestling organization its
major do you feel pressure from the
community do you feel how historic this
is yes the short answer is yes it's it's
not lost on me there definitely is a
little bit of pressure there because
obviously I want to represent to the
best of my ability but at the same time
you know I can only speak for myself to
a certain degree you know so my views my
ideas are purely my views and my ideas
and I and I hope that doesn't get lost
on the people sure but yeah there's
definitely a bit of responsibility there
okay so who could kick each other's ass
first
yeah the experience okay it's the
experience it's not about the
ass-kicking well mainly cuz I gotta get
it done quick and I feel like fighting
for a long time so I gotta you know just
kill all my thumbs cuz you're sitting
here don't get on the bad side well you
know I he was young very young I
remember when his first like matches and
he was young like almost prepubescent
yes great yeah and so I think there's
that
but like auntie aspect of respect there
you've got to beat up your nephew
alright you sort of explained the
persona of jungleboy young boy yeah I
mean general boy is um you know it's
it's kind of a classic character you see
Tarzan like George of the gentleman so
it's kind of that but it has a new twist
on it because it flips throwing people
on their heads and whatnot so it's I
like to think that it is like that that
age-old character and the new twist of a
young guys but you can never cut your
hair no I know cuz it really good now
now I'm stuck with it yeah right
especially my contract congratulations
you guys thank you for taking the time
to sit down I'm very excited for you my
family's excited we'll be watching yeah
awesome
[Music]